[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hello
Walter hi Martin I just wanted to get it
a a head start again is that why you
jumped out of the blocks like a racer
yeah we have to get this going we have
to get this going you realize that when
we're not making friends here from
people in high
places yeah how
many how long ago did you did this do
this the first time many years ago but
we'll update it to see what the problem
is yeah and has it changed it's gotten
worse it's gotten worse it's amazing
that you've been doing this for 38 years
and nothing's changed it's just getting
worse but exactly the same message that
you've been given that's been coming for
180 years is still running it's still
running so let's open with a word of
prayer our heavenly father we thank you
that we can be here and we do this
discussion we ask that you Enlighten our
minds Enlighten the viewers and help us
to get through this in jesus' name amen
amen I don't think we'll be able to do
this in one session because the Jesuits
are such a clandestine
organization and so
undermining that uh to discuss all the
aspects is impossible in any case unless
you do a long series on them and then
you will not have the full
story so we're not going to talk about
the their political intrigues we're not
going to talk about their school Mastery
we're not going to talk about their
infiltration in business and commerce
and government and all of those things
and we're not going to talk about their
diabolical history of them having been
banned here and there and the other
we're going to talk about the spiritual
aspect and I think people will be
surprised to see where the tentacles yes
because their aim is to destroy
protestantism and to get rid of that
poisonous
ASP which they call the Bible yeah and
to replace it with their wishy-washy
versions that do not called Spade Spades
and allow lots of room for gnosticism
yeah yeah so I know that some of our own
people will already have their hackles
up but sit down and listen for a change
instead of jumping out of your blocks
true watch these statements and this we
don't say anything this comes from
themselves yes now wy's history on the
Reformation is one of the best sources
out there so let's start with a quote
from that and he writes and I like the
way they write they still uh knew how to
use the English vernacular that's true I
mean you get paragraphs that's actually
one
sentence
yes protestantism is not solely the
outcome of human progress it is no mere
principle of perfect ability inherent in
humanity and ranking as one of its
native powers in virtue of which when
Society becomes corrupt it can purify
itself and when it is arrested in its
course by some external force or stops
from exhaustion it can recruit its
energies and set forward a new on its
path it's a very profound statement so
let's just simplify that yeah we don't
have it within ourselves to be
Protestants it must be a Divine spark it
must come from
outside it is not something where
Humanity can self-correct itself if God
doesn't intervene in your heart you will
never gain the principles you will never
understand and you will end up where
humanity is now wow You'll Go from bad
to worse you will never go from bad to
better no and even if it appears Martin
by deception to be going better it's
actually getting worse that's a profound
statement I think that sums up the first
paragraph it is neither the product of
individual reason nor the result of the
joint thought and energy of the species
it's
divine protestantism is a principle
which has its origin outside of human
society it is a Divine graft on the
intellectual and moral nature of of man
whereby new vitalities and forces are
introduced into it and the human stem
yields henceforth a nobler fruit so you
cannot do this by yourself it's an
outside so Martin if you reject
protestantism you are rejecting God oh
well
yeah it is the descendant of a heaven
born influence which allies itself with
all the instincts and powers of the
individual with all the laws and
Cravings of society and which quickening
both the individual and the social being
into a new life and directing their
efforts to nobler objects permits the
highest development of which human
humanity is capable and the fullest
possible accomplishment of all the grand
ends in a word protestantism is revived
Christianity and it is the enemy
of the forces of Darkness for sure true
Christianity has to be a
eradicated in their thinking yeah it is
an obstacle so this is the history of
protestant by Wy and it's a it's a very
very reputable source so let's follow
that up with a quote from the great
controversy mhm throughout christiandom
protest protestantism was menaced by
formidable foes the first Triumph of the
Reformation passed Rome summoned new
forces hoping to accomplish its
destruction at this time the order of
the Jesuits was created the most cruel
unscrupulous and Powerful of all the
champions of popery there was no crime
too great for them to commit no
deception too base for them to practice
no disguise too difficult for them to
assume vowed to Perpetual poverty and
humility it was their studied aim to
secure wealth and power to be devoted to
the overthrow of protestantism and the
reestablishment of papal
Supremacy Martin that is the kindest way
in which you can tell them off yeah I
would use far
more you I would use adjectives far more
freely and they would not be kind kind
adjectives and it's not to be cruel no
it's a fact of history and once you
realize what they are up to You'll
everybody will feel the there so much
blood dripping from their
fingers so much vile usage of means like
drugs
coercion weapons Warfare murder that
it's
unbelievable that this Society is still
functioning today they are satanic
because they have no sympathy for
Humanity no they have no sympathy for
Humanity they' have been devoid of human
sensibility because they have vowed to
be like a corpse as long as the
interests of the church are met it
doesn't matter how many people die in
the process or how many are used to
destruction so when appearing as me of
their order they wore a Garb of sanctity
visiting prisons and hospitals
ministering to the sick and the poor
professing to have renounced the world
and bearing the sacred name of Jesus who
went about doing
good but under this blameless exterior
the most criminal and deadly purposes
were often concealed it was a
fundamental principle of the order that
The end justifies the means by this code
lying theft perjury assassination were
not only pardonable but commendable when
they served the interests of the church
under various disguises the Jesuit
worked their ways into offices of State
climbing up to be counselors of kings
and shaping the policy of Nations Martin
this is not conjecture this is history
yeah and we have hundreds of sources
that we could put onto the screen to
verify this from presidents of the
United States to world leaders to
thousands upon thousands who have
realized this over the years and this
leopard never changes his spots he only
digs like a mole a deeper hole into
which he hides his perversity yeah yeah
it's that's per that's
exactly so let's just quote one more in
18 16 John Adams wrote to President
Jefferson shall we not have regular
swarms of them here in as many disguises
as only the king of the gypsies can
assume dressed as painters Publishers
writers and school Masters if ever there
was a body of men who merited Eternal
damnation on Earth and in hell it is the
Society of
lolos so I don't think he liked them I I
don't think he
had very nice thoughts about them and
Martin with my little experience in my
life getting on to 76 now did you
realize I'm getting to be an Old Goat
old yes in which eyes but I take heart
because when I look at people like Trump
or Pope Francis I said what if these
coders can do it I can do it too right
you're you're still young a youngster
yes I would I would again love to add
some adjectives there but I'll I'll
leave it at that and be as kind as I
possibly can it's good yes which is zero
to the power of a billion I cannot be
kind I do not have one kind word towards
them because even their socalled
philanthropy is a deception and a lie
yes the so-called Christian world is to
be a theater of great and decisive
actions men in Authority will enact laws
controlling the conscience after the
example of the papacy that's what
they're aiming
for Babylon will make all nations drink
of the wine of the wroth of a
fornication Every Nation will be
involved nobody nobody escapes their
minations nobody that is so important
because we think oh no they can't can't
be everywhere H we'll have to see
because babon Has Fallen
we need to know why it's Fallen because
they drank this wi and who poured this
wine for them the Jesuits in their
various disguises pretending to be
Protestant preachers in the Protestant
World pret pretending to be imams in the
Muslim World pretending to be the
leaders in the Indian society as fake
and who knows as what pretending to be
the best Hindus the best Buddhists you
name them they are there in their
disguise undermining and producing a
spirituality which is from below and not
from above yeah yeah all right Martin
how do you go about this you must start
replacing moral absolutes with
relativism if you want to fight against
God you have to try and pretend that you
are using the weapons of God and pervert
them to such an extent that people think
that they are serving God when they are
serving
Baal and that's the Crux of the matter
because when the first time I saw this I
mean this really opened my eyes because
you you are so duped because you think
that this these people and these um
denominations theyve good Christians
well you served and worshiped in
denominations like that sure and these
people are not to blame blame no it's
not you that sit in there no so who
brought you out it must have been a
Divine implant God talked to your heart
Y and these poor people let's make it
quite clear if you are deceived it's the
worst thing in the world so I feel
incredibly sorry for all those
denominations that have drunken of this
wine but isn't that why we are doing
these lectures and and to wake people up
so that you not that that's why we doing
these things so that people can be
enlightened to know this and not be
misled anymore correct correct so we're
not against
denominations we're against the wine
that is being imbibed in without them
even knowing not even the pastors know
nobody knows because the Jesuits have so
subtly poisoned the the streams that
they think that the drinking from a
Divine Source when they're drinking from
from a foul system yeah yeah so let's
see how they replace moral
absolutes Hebrews 12:25 to 28 see that
ye refuse not him that speaketh for if
they escaped not who refused him that
spake on Earth how much
more shall not we escape if we turn away
from him that speaketh from Heaven whose
voice then shook the Earth but now has
promised saying yet once more I will
shake not the Earth only but the heaven
and this word yet once more signifies
the removing of those things that are
shaken as of things that are made and
that those things which cannot be shaken
May remain wherefore we receiving a
kingdom which cannot be moved let us
have Grace whereby we may serve God
acceptably with reverence and godly fear
for our God is a consuming fire Martin
is retribution coming for sure it's
coming yeah
and if there was a shaking then there
will be a shaking at the end mhm MH and
if you do not listen to The Voice where
do I hear his voice Martin through the
scriptures
um isn't he called the word yeah so this
is our guideline that's it the only one
not some
Guru or some spiritual advisor or coach
who stands there spab Babylonian vne in
experience no no no because anybody can
give you an
experience another statement which is
interesting is bear in mind that it is
none but God that can hold an argument
with Satan don't think you can tread
onto his ground and play Mr Big Wheel
you're going to come off second best
yeah so let's have a look at
protestantism versus the ideology of the
so-called Society of Jesus but it's a
totally different
Jesus Luther's appeal was to submit the
conscience directly to God through the
word and Lala's Drive was to submit the
conscience to the
papacy ignatian spirituality was to be
achieved through spiritual exercises by
substituting imagination and encounter
theology for the reality of faith so the
second one is a sherad
yeah you are creating your own
experience and inviting demons to
embellish it the first one is based on
God and submission to his word and the
two are diametrically opposed to each
other they are the problem is that they
make the second one so beautifully G yes
that it seems that you are actually
spiritually so if you are involved in
this somebody can actually put a Bible
in your hand and it wouldn't change you
one iot because the experience is
nominative so let's take another quote
from history another excellent source
Merl ab's history of the Reformation of
the 16th century this is a amazing
document AB
enigo now enigo was a short version of
ignatus of Lola so we could read the
Ignus of Lala instead of feeling that
his remorse was sent to drive him to the
foot of the cross persuaded himself that
these inward reproaches proceeded not
from God but from the devil it's a very
dangerous thing to say that that which
is from God is from the devil yeah that
is the sin against the Holy Spirit
correct and he resolved never more to
think of his sins to erase them from his
memory and bury them in Eternal Oblivion
Luther turned towards Christ Lola fell
only upon
himself Visions came ear long to confirm
enigo in the convictions at which he had
arrived enigo did not seek truth in the
Holy scriptures but imagined in their
place immediate communication with the
world of spirits
Luther on taking his doctor's degree had
pledged his oath to the holy scriptures
Lola at his time bound himself to dreams
and visions and chical apparitions
became the principle of his life and his
faith experiential
religion takes the place of the word and
if we can say if you go to most of the
charismatic churches yes you see very
little about the Bible and very much
about experience correct so Martin let's
see how this works let's give a little
example let's say you're happily
married and uh some
cauliflower bad eared
individual starts uh communicating with
your
wife and subtly through neurolinguistic
programming which is infused by the the
Devil Himself mhm convinces her that
this new cauliflower baeed individual
with the buck teeth is the bee's knees
and you are a useless
provider then very soon the affections
are moved to the new individual and no
matter how you speak you will not be
able to convince them so you might be
the best provider Under the Sun but this
one brings a flower every day which you
cannot eat in the first place but as
soon the affections are drawn away and
the marriage comes to an
end that is how the devil works with
those who are affiliated to Christ
that's it and then the experience
something that feels so good cannot be
from the devil that's the Bible has a
very sure answer for that the seventh
commandment do not commit adultery yeah
so if the person that said it is written
that's it
please your neurolinguistic program is
not going to work on me there's the door
make sure it hits you on the way out
yeah but that's then the problem would
have been solved right the word would
have solved been word based and not
feeling based correct all right you
might have struggled with it for a while
of course but but with prayer you would
have overcome it and you would have
realized what a disaster that would have
been
right and that's so important because
this is happening all the time now this
is how the devil works with those who
are affiliated to
Jesus so let's have a look at these
friendly
Jesuits this is father aturo sza he is
the 31st general of the Society of
Jesus and he is in the background you
don't hear much about him he's the
underground Pope yeah the black pope but
he makes sure to have a little piece of
white attached there which is a symbol
of his own righteousness which he
doesn't
have because the principles of the
Jesuit order have never changed yeah and
the black pope and the white Pope in
this case both being Jesuits MH walk
hand in hand the one supporting the
other who's holding on to who there
Martin for being steadied on the way
yeah the white Pope is the white Pope is
being steadied by the black pope and uh
if you ever go into their history the
black Pope's
power cannot be
curtailed he will do what he deems to
have to do in order to further the
objects yeah so the white Pope leans on
him it's a very good picture it is and
the interesting thing is that the
allegiance of the black pope is supposed
to be to the white Pope yes it's a very
difficult situation but I think they
know exactly what they they know exactly
how this works out yes and underneath
that white go you can be sure he's
wearing a black
trousers and this is the solidarity that
they have standing there side by side
with their
conclave where certain decisions are
made made and introduced in the most
subtle way into every field of
[Music]
society they look so happy they're
smiling because they think they have the
ascendancy yeah but they don't know what
is waiting for them so let's look how
they operate kalana of course this was a
Jesuit he was the main architect of
Vatican 2 the council where many
Protestants believe that Rome actually
changed definitely now we did one on
that right and we showed that they
hadn't changed at all in fact they did
not change they went more Sinister
underground infiltrating and all the
previous um Theology and statements of
poery was actually enhanced absolutely
correct so he was the most important
Catholic Theologian in the 20th
century and you know he put Theology and
philosophy in
dialogue now Martin once you start doing
that once you're mixing TR and truth and
error and put them into dialogue then
you have exactly that because what has
truth and error got in common with each
other
absolutely nothing and he originated
this new religious category called
Anonymous
Christianity saying it embraced Buddhist
various other non-christians
atheists and you know anyone basically
who is upright and caring the Bible says
there's nobody upright and caring
because the heart is exing exceedingly
Wicked yeah so what they actually also
did is at Vatican 2 they embraced all
the other religions as well absolutely
and the atheist put them all into one
Camp those are all those that reject
Christ so it's amazing they actually
were this up until then this institution
that didn't embrace them so they were
very strict if you can say it like that
and then all of a sudden the whole world
just like wondering the whole world
wondering wow they must have changed
look how embracing they are now before
they killed you now they embrace
you so all you needed basically was some
kind of faith in God whether you knew
that you had it or
not okay okay so they were all part of
Christianity even if they didn't call
themselves Christians if you like they
called it pagans who had received Grace
but were not aware of it so basically
this philosophy says everybody's saved
yeah what's a point
then that's why Pope Francis could say
don't proze correct all right now I know
we're repeating a little bit here but
this just to give a little bit of
background we'll get to the spiritual
side just now we have to show what's
where they so they disguised themselves
in black suits and ties rather than in
their Jesuit
robes but here is ratzinger who was not
himself a Jesuit but was highly
influenced by them of course and they
were the architects of Vatican 2o so
it's very becoming that ringa became a
pope so R's motto was our Lord must
conform to the world not it to him now M
that is a most diabolical statement it's
it's a joke doesn't the first verse of
the Lord's Prayer say thy kingdom come
thy will be done in earth as it is in
heaven yeah no not now Heaven has to
change kingom kdom up there has to
change to conform to his satanic
Majesty's Kingdom and another architect
that was important in Vatican 2 was uh
Cardinal
sunin and he was responsible for the
charismatic Revival so M the charismatic
movement is a child of the papacy it's
sad but true it's a Jesuit
construct so what did he do he received
the Templeton prize in
1976 he was also a Mason and he was
initiated on June 15
1967 because being a Mason he could work
with the Protestant preachers who were
also Masons yeah and some of those
so-called Protestant preachers were
probably Jesuits in Disguise we will not
know until the final day
and he stated this Cardinal since I've
had this charismatic experience my
allegiance to the Holy Father as the
Vicor of Christ in the world has been
heightened and strengthened my
appreciation for Mary as the co- rempis
and mediator of my salvation has been
assured my appreciation of the mass as
the sacrifice of Christ has now been
heightened so did it take him to the
word or fur further away further away
can you just explain to us what this
charismatic experience what it means
well this is an experiential experience
which is based on the principles of Lala
and not on the principles of the word
you are negating the word and putting
the experience in the place thereof so
that's why it's so dangerous in the
charismatic movement all right so he
fixes his attention on the pope instead
of on Jesus Christ he fixes his
intention on Mary as a redempt when the
Bible says there's no other name whereby
you can be saved rather than on Jesus
and then the mass which is a Perpetual
sacrifice is also elevated is in opinion
where Jesus said by one sacrifice he has
forever made perfect so this is totally
anti-christian but the experience makes
it so-called
Christian now who did they use to get to
the Protestant World well they used a
lady by the name of Katherine Joanna
kman who lived from 1907 to
1976 and she was a faith healer in
America she believed in Miracles and
deliverance by the power of the Holy
Spirit and was part of the Pentecostal
arm of the Protestant
Christianity so protestantism was
infiltrated with this mode of thinking
now concerning the
Jesuits Alberto who claimed to have been
a Jesuit said Katherine kouman was one
of Rome's greatest undercover agents
assigned to penetrate the Pentecostal
and Protestants through the charismatic
movement she was a master of hypnosis
and had tremendous psychic powers as a
reward for her outstanding work she was
granted a private audience with the Pope
what a wonderful reward wouldn't you be
excited if that happened to you
Martin no not unfortunately not as a
result of her work most Now teach
Unity but seldom preach separation and
Holiness which Rome
dreaded so if you're separated from them
they have to use every Power to bridge
that
Gap so let's jump to an article in zenet
from 200
13 francis's press conference on return
flight from
Brazil you asked about the charismatic
renewal movement I'll tell you something
in the years at the end of the 70s
beginning of the80s I couldn't stand
them once speaking of them I had said
this phrase they confuse a liturgical
celebration with a sambba school I said
this but I repented
then I got to know them better it's also
true that the movement with good
advisors has gone on good on a good path
and now I think this movement has done
so much good to the church in general
Martin if the Jesuits actually did this
in the first place they have to distance
themselves and then embrace it so that
it's never their fault at the beginning
they have to say no we don't have
anything to do with or like he said I
could not stand it but I repented yes
then it looks like you know he's been
one over when actually he's the snake in
the grass wow the Holy Spirit does what
he
wishes then he does the work of
harmonizing but I think the movements
are a grace these movements that have
the spirit of the church it renews us
and each one seeks his movement
according to his
charism which the spirit takes him
wherever the spirit leads let's just go
the word has been negated yeah all right
Martin so if you introduce this mode of
thinking where protestantism had
separated itself from false ideologies
and from
Catholicism this spirit will tend to
reunite them right yeah let's just make
sure let's look at this video here's the
[Music]
deal I believe that the Catholic church
and the Christian church we going to
come
together right
now father I thank you in the name of
Jesus
God for a mighty baptism on the Catholic
Church
SC Holy Spirit more fire Jesus name fire
of Heaven in the name of Jesus we're a
delegation a Catholic delegation and I
come from
Italy and I bring you a salute from 150
million charismatic
Catholics we want to Lou kiss your feet
as
Catholics and just honor you with this
gesture right now
[Music]
can you now see why the devil fought for
the lie that a Catholic couldn't be
saved come
on this Pentecostal outpouring in our
time
started in the
Vatican it didn't start in the zeusa
street it didn't start in Topeka Kansas
it was a pope that
invoked
faith and asked God for a new
Pentecost praise
[Music]
God Martin that's the first time I heard
a word of Truth out of that man's mouth
so
yeah it gives you chills it gives you
chills now shouldn't every Protestant
have his hackles up and say whoa here's
something wrong here of course but they
don't no we Embrace we embrace it so
what have the Jesuits succeeded in doing
of bringing ignatian spirituality into
protestantism in many shapes and forms
and
disguises and how do you get the world
to accept this and the young people to
accept this why didn't you drug them so
that they are not capable of independent
thought yeah and and you disguise it
under love and the other thing is if you
can just think that is why we after
we've just seen this video why the Bible
says that Babylon has fallen it has
fallen it has completely Fallen because
it has drunken the wine the Babylonian
lie of a Jesuit construct the Lala
experience
of communicating directly with
demons
now the hippie movement with its free
love and free morals I mean that's
wonderful if you can use you know the
testosterone levels of the youth and
channel them into
debauchery and enhance the experience
with drugs and then add a charismatic
experience to that oh yes then sin
becomes a virtue
like the Mormon prophet said through the
gift of sin man can achieve yeah you
know Joy this is really an interesting
philosophy now who was behind this
destruction of the moral fiber of
society it was the Jesuits obviously
again it was the Jesuits so let's break
down protestantism the Jesus people the
hippie movement was led by the Jesuits
such as Ma
from Georgetown
University this led to the
anti-establishment Jesus with long hair
and let your hair down philosophy do you
know that I saw this on some of our own
churches as well oh for sure you that's
why people must when they see what's
going on here just put yourself into
your own church where you currently are
which denomination that might be yes and
ask and see if this is prevalent yes I I
was preaching in one of those let your
hair down churches I was horrified that
changed the church into a strobe light
theater The Love Gospel The Liberation
gospel the Prosperity Gospel oh how many
preachers are into that today
Martin the coffee house Jesus The Rock
and Roll Jesus the existential Jesus who
meets the needs of all culture Creeds
and
aspirations so depending on what you
like whether you like heavy metal
whether you like soft pop or whether you
like the more classical music I can
supply all you needs all of it I mean
the coffee house Jesus that's some more
subtle one that will go into the more
conservative churches but let's just
fill your head with caffeine that you
can't think will'll cut the supply of
blood to your brain by 40% so you become
a zombie yeah and can
consume all this from them correct so
here you have him our Jesuit uh deceiver
in 1961 he began teaching theology at
Georgetown University in Washington and
remained there until his death in 1962
he befriended Robert Kennedy's family
and became a tutor for his children
that's a scary statement Martin
considering present day uh Power
structures and well we've shown that he
that Junior acknowledged that he grew up
in Jesuit schools and he
correct every day throughout the 1960s
he spent several hours with the Kennedy
family teaching assisting and helping
out he also became a friend and
confident of President and Mrs Kennedy
and counseled the family and offered
daily mass for them after JFK's
assassination later he consulted rfk's
children after their father's murder too
but it was Martin Luther King Jr who
changed his life again
so love death hate the Love Gospel and
of course associated with the drug
gospel so what did they do they started
introducing
nihilism which is a philosophy of nature
remember they were going to put
Christianity
or Theology and philosophy in communion
with each other so nihilism is the
notion that ethical Norms are rationally
unjustifiable and a consequent mood of
despair of a life's emptiness is the
result n defined the concept as the
situation which exist when everything is
permitted so Mar in order to to uh
counteract this depression you first
have to create the depression yeah
that's true you have to create the
emptiness so let everything go can I
maybe just say so how do you do that
very good you create a wall you
destroy the society yes then you get
into a depression there's no money
there's nothing and you come out of that
oh let's get back to some standards and
Norms but please not biblical ones no
and let's have a hero the pope yeah and
not Jesus Christ and let the Holy Spirit
convince you that you're on the right
road with all kinds of
manifestations and so they bring in the
Eastern philosophies and the thoughts on
yoga and this and that and the other and
Eastern meditation and they use the
music industry
to this into the minds of
humanity in the Rick Martin interview
with Eric John Phelps Phelps claims that
the Beatles were Jesuit controlled and
that the drug world is controlled by
Rome VI the mafia which is Jesuit
controlled but that's quite a statement
in his book so I'm not saying it he's
saying it uh I think
it's not only plausible m M but more
than that the more you study it the more
you study it and of course the devil's
signs and the 666 symbol they were the
first rock man band to use the devil's
Triad on a record cover so introduce
these IDE and like you also mentioned in
a previous one that we did long ago they
were the more um lovable ones you had
the the the naughty ones on one side
that were more
um Rolling Stones and those type of
people then you got the Beatles that
were embracing such a bro broader
conservative Daniel already said all
kinds of music all kinds of music and
what kind of philosophy did Elvis
Presley for example bring into the mix
Elvis would sometimes read passages to
his audiences from blavatsky's book The
Voice of the silence it's a book that
promotes Eastern Hindu meditation as a
path to
self-realization while the Beatles
practiced and promoted maharishi's
Transcendental
Meditation while he was in India John
Lennon wrote to a fan Transcendental
Meditation is not opposed to any
religion it is based on the basic truths
of all religions the common denominator
actual experience of God known as
Vatican 2 launched in Rome with more
than 2,000 Catholic bishops from around
the
world Vatican 2 helped paid the way for
Interfaith ISM promoting Unity between
the world's religions by sharing the
Catholic Church's Mystic Treasures that
is its contemplative
Traditions the term contemplative life
was historically related to various
monastic orders of monks and nuns
whose lifestyles are oriented towards
aesthetic practices and contemplative
prayer a form of
mysticism we were asked by the Vatican
to to get involved in dialogue with
Eastern meditation and with Easter
monasticism as the area in which
Christianity had the most common basis
according to Vatican 2 they would play
the main role in the evangelization of
the world and that's exactly what
happened so Martin once you get into
this mysticism you are actually
communicating with demons that's a scary
thing because you don't real most people
don't realize it you know in my own life
remember when I started studying the
scriptures and I'd had all these
problems in my house and I'd had the
Catholic church around to uh get rid of
them do an exorcism
and this Catholic Exorcist an elderly
gentleman came into my house said a mass
he was thrown around all over the place
in the house there was a real demonic
presence
there and uh when he left the problem
was
resolved and then over a year of Peace
eventually by circumstances which people
can look at other sources I came back to
the
scriptures and I discovered you know
that the scripture is the
norm and when I started putting my foot
into the scriptures I got a phone call A
year later from this very priest who was
telling me I better stop doing what I
was doing and meaning stop studying the
scripture yes go back to the Catholic
Church stop studying this
stuff because my father was dead was
suffering in
purgatory as a consequence have you by
this time already studied the state of
the Dead I knew about the state of the
Dead by then so my ears pricked up as I
was speaking to him on the
phone M this was 38 39 years ago yeah
and I said to him uh how do you know
that my father is suffering in purgatory
who told you
that and he didn't bat an eyelid he told
me the nuns told him the nuns that never
see the light of day in the or the world
that stay in their Monastery in a
certain monastic structure there in Cape
Town and I said to him well fair enough
but how do these nuns know that my
father is suffering in purgatory yeah
and he said they communicate with the
spirits and the spirit told them so I
knew they were holding sanes yeah and
were subject to the teaching of demons
but this is how it works so having done
this having brought in this Eastern
mysticism into the whole of society
because if you influence the youth
remember they they plan over decades and
Millenia you can see this if you
influence the youth in this day and age
that becomes the Adult World in the next
day and age and then you introduce other
things you know like the Rave culture
into the Next Generation that's your
generation yeah all right that's it so
first you had that hippie generation
that's my generation then they
introduced all of these ideas through
the music through the Beatles through
all of these things then they went into
the Rave culture where they escalated
the drug usage and it destroyed the
mental fabric of
humanity you partook of that white
disgusting powder yeah it's some other
you proud of it not at all not do mean
you know the truth but while you in it
that's why I say it's it's crazy but
while you're in this even if you're in a
false religious system you if you don't
get woke waken
up one of the reasons why people take
these drugs like ecstasy and tick and
all of these is because it gives you
this elevated feeling of a higher
consciousness you're are suddenly so
much more aware I understand the world
know from the devil's perspective it's
feeling based because it's Euphoria it's
all of these things and it links so good
you can even do that and still go to a
charismatic church because the feeling
is still there there all right Martin
you got out of it does everybody get out
of it no unfortunately does the devil
care how many lives he's destroyed how
many young people's Minds is destroyed
does he care not at all I cannot wait
for the day of Retribution get rid of
this and then you change it having now
destroyed the moral fiber of society
well then you bring in hius
caring
Z Martin I want to throw up but let's
carry
on God is dead therefore life's answers
lie within the S mhm you know there's
nothing to live for how are we going to
get it let's get it out of yourself no
no no don't don't don't pick up that
good book just leave the good book alone
so self-esteem and the Christian
psychology so you start with the
selfesteem and you write books on it oh
like Robert Schuler did and uh all of
these high Freemasons did you bring it
into the movies especially the cartoons
and everybody says You Must Believe In
Yourself yes believe in yourself so how
to get taught that the soul would then
authenticate Itself by showing concern
for others or
caring that's Jesuit philosophy you know
you hand out the soup you wash the feet
and uh you don't care that they carry on
in their squala but you have been so
elevated you've done a wonderful job
that's where the problem comes in they
take something good and they come and
put it mess it up mess it up all right
so once you have authenticated this so
This existential caring zor in German is
based on da which means in being what
that's saying I'm God yeah yeah this is
disgusting this is the religion of self
the religion of antichrist God being
removed the church sets the standard and
educates coaches M the masses through
Christian psychology spiritual directors
neur neur linguistic programming caring
Labs Etc until a new spiritual formation
is achieved you have an entire new
spirituality which is not words word
based but experience based and works
based so let's take it a step further
you must develop a new
morality so you must become the caring
church so father Gustavo gutterz what
does he have to say on the issue I hat
it how they call them SES father you
have one father your Earthly father is
your Earthly father and then you have a
heavenly father and none of these people
are
fathers we learn in Catholicism courtesy
of the theologizing of Father Gustavo
gutiz that the church in Latin America
must take a clear stand against social
injustice you have a new enemy that's it
the enemy is not sin it's social
injustice but let create the social
injustice so that you can uh address the
social inj you can be the hero
correct so let's create social injustice
Let's uh do it on the basis of
race now those that introduced the
racial systems in the world whether it
was in our country or anywhere else in
the world they were all high Masons
that's
it and in favor of the Revolutionary
process and Via Leonardo buff that The
Church Must be defined in terms of
energy charism and the progress of the
world it's become a world church now not
a church of Salvation and gospel the
church's activities on behalf of social
justice or human rights are not merely
Preparatory to the real mission of the
church as the notion of pre-
evangelization had it before Vatican 2
the church's commitment to and
involvement in the struggle for social
justice peace and human rights is an
essential or constitutive part of its
Mission this is what the gospel is about
social justice and this is the reason
why so many Christian churches will go
into ecumenism with Rome of course it
seems so right because there is so much
social injustice which they created yeah
if people believed that all people were
created equal if people would believe
that by one blood he has created all the
nations of the world in Christ we would
be United and none of this nonsense
would have taken place the Jesuits are
at the base of it and their Day of
Reckoning is coming com yeah so now
let's jump to the present this is
September
20124 Pope to popular movements fight
for social and economic Justice is this
a a man of the Gospel he's he's from the
devil that's it so he meets with
represent tentatives of popular
movements making the 10th anniversary of
their first encounter at the Vatican and
encourage the fight against social
injustice reiterating his
proposal for Universal basic income and
higher taxes for billionaires would that
make the poor masses happy it will yes
of course it will make them happy will
they bind them to his Apron Strings yes
where he can feed them their this soup
of why with false doctr of can it will
make them happy but will this help them
no nothing they'll remain as poor as
they were before because it will get
worse not better so take heed that you
do not your righteousness before men to
be seen of them Martin is this a rebuke
to them oh for sure this is a rebuke to
ell philanthropist if it's not done you
can be a philanthropist in the right way
that's it if you're not you should be
one in the right way but if you're doing
it to be seen before men yes and to get
into the
headlines Well they claimed to be very
jealous for the honor of the law self-
Glory was the real object which they
sought and Christ would make it manifest
to them that the lovers of self is a
transgressor of the law pardon we have
to be very careful so let's prepare the
minds of the people for this new
spirituality so ignatian spirituality .c
let's go to the present web pages the
spiritual exercises are a compilation of
meditations prayers contemplative
practices developed by St ignasius Lola
to help people deepen their relationship
with God I'm sorry with demons yeah
unfortunately for centuries the
exercises were most commonly given as a
long retreat of about 30 days in
solitude and S
Ence Martin so if you're living in the
Solitude and silence your head can be
filled with all kinds of garbage other
than the word of God whereas if you
picked up your word and you read it you
would be better educated it's so
important in recent years there's been a
renewed emphasis on the spiritual
exercises as a program for Lay people
the most common way of going through the
exercises now is a retreat in daily life
which involves a monthlong program of
daily prayer and meeting with a
spiritual director Martin I don't want
to meet with a spiritual director I want
to meet with Jesus exactly and I want
the inpouring of the Holy Spirit to
introduce him and his word to me exactly
go come through the scriptures not
sitting alone and waiting to hear what
he has to say read the scriptures and
through the holy spirit's help
you'll understand what he wants to say
yes no no no but I want to listen to
what the spirit says without him telling
me about Jesus and his word so the
exercises have also been adapted in many
other ways to meet the needs of modern
people no not the needs the destruction
yeah so how excited is the Jesuit
General when he sees his diabolic work
bearing fruit with the youth let's look
at it Martin how being a Jesuit has
shaped him as Pope uh you know he's
somebody who talks a lot about
discernment which is a really important
part of Jesuit spirituality and I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about um you know what what we can all
learn from Pope Francis about
discernment Pope
Francis is not only a Jesuit a
Christian and discernment is is part of
Christan Christianity we are about to
celebrate Pentecost in a few days so we
can renew our idea of being Guided by
the spirit discernment is the skill
every Christian needs to be guided by
the Holy Spirit and that's why ignan
spirituality is so pointed on that and
ignatian spiritual exercises are a kind
of disend
school that he he
learning himself so following the
spiritual exercises every person can be
helped to hear the voice of God calling
him to a fully human life and to decide
to follow that voice no to take to make
an election
and and you can also maybe remember that
the the success of ignasius with the
spiritual exercises were among
University students he was University an
old University student and he get
together with some Young University
students all the first Companions of
ignasius were University students
gathered by the experience of the
spiritual exercises
so the this school of discernment has
been a very very fruitful for for us in
all the stage of our life and apostolate
yeah so so all Jesuits do the spiritual
exercises but one thing that's always
struck me struck me about the society is
the the diverse directions that Jesuits
go on from there so you have Jesuits who
are teachers doctors actors podcasters
uh everything you can think of um and
you know that's clearly part of the
Jesuit charism and a strength of the
order um but as the person who's on top
of that at the neck how do you how do
you manage such a diverse
Workforce well F of all I every day I
discover something new that yes we are
doing mner was uh very
enlightening just everything we've been
seeing and saying about them didn't he
just acknowledge all of it he
acknowledged all of it but uh there were
a few subtle things which people might
not just pick up without having studied
what they are doing
uh he said that discernment MH is a very
important thing but where does the
discernment discernment comes from comes
from inside yes and the exercises and
the exercises it doesn't come from from
the word of God and then it says it live
it leads towards living a fully human
life now I don't think many people will
pick that up no because that is the new
definition of salvation according to to
Vatican 2 according to Vatican 2 to be
saved is to live a fully human life that
means you only have this life on Earth
because you won't have a future one yeah
you're basically being destroyed
spiritually so what does it mean to be
saved to live a fully human life or does
to be saved mean to be covered by the
blood of the Lamb to have his imputed
and imparted righteousness so that you
may stand on the sea of glass with all
the holy people of all the ages and be
fitted for a society in heaven that is
salvation not this nonsense that they
are shoving down your throat and that is
for an everlasting life yes not for a
fully human the devil promis you
promises you a human life here didn't he
do it to Jesus as well he promised him I
will give you all of this this is the
Temptation Of The Devil and some he
gives more than others
and they become the idols
yes Martin I I feel a surge of righteous
indignation yeah cuz he'll do it to the
rock star he'll do it to the sport star
and he'll do it to the mega preacher who
preaches oh give your seed to me that I
might buy an an airplane for myself and
justify it you know Mar they make me
sick but it's unfortunately um if you
look at this and you see like you've
mentioned they don't think in years they
think in Millennia no they think in
Millennia they're thinking in
Generations that's it and if you think
and you can see how this infiltration
has worked and where we are in society
now it is crazy so let's how see how
they
work Jesuit Retreats last four weeks and
they are you know Guided by someone that
they call a coach only the director who
has grasped the mind and heart of
ignatian
spirituality which is distinguished
servant service of Christ it's not
Martin it's of the church MH can fulfill
his task of adapting the exercises to
the precise needs of the individual or
group to whom he is speaking so he's
like a serpent like a chameleon yeah an
experienced Retreat master who knows the
exercises well will make numerous little
adjust adustment in his approaches to
the meditation to fit the education
temperament role in life age bracket and
interests of his audience these trained
Jesuits are behind these things and this
comes directly from ignatian Lola
spiritual exercises this is their Source
you see and the thing is they can also
do that this in preaching when they are
preaching they can use all of these and
adjust themselves you I believe many of
these Mega preachers are Jesuits in this
guys well versed in the spiritual
exercises and how to dup a society into
buying Babylonian
wine all right so what does it really
mean so the spiritual exercises of Lala
this comes from their own Apostolic
writings the first rule is all judgment
laid aside Martin that's the first rule
you should never do that is the first
Angel's
message judgement is come yes and don't
lay aside your reasoning power so there
must judgment and then discern I mean
didn't he just mentioned earlier the
discernment so now we've got their
discernment what discernment you've got
to be a corpse you've got to be a dead
individual listening to
a uh experienced instructor in spiritual
exercises so all judgment laid aside we
ought to have our mind ready and prompt
to obey in all the true spouse of Christ
Our Lord which is our holy mother the
church Hier aial so that's the first
thing that you have to do you listen to
what the church says and ignore what the
Bible
says the 13th rule we're not going to go
through them all of course is to hold
that the white which I see is black if
the hierarchial church decides it so L
this is disgusting that means may not
have any own thinking in terms of are
they right or are they wrong how does it
line up with what the scripture says and
I think if you are then steeped in the
spiritual
exercises like he said you'll get your
discernment from that if because you're
listening to all this garbage being fed
to you by demons yes you will get the
same correct thinking as they and then
you have to basically say
martin that because the
Spirit uh who gave the Ten Commandments
to our holy mother the
church if if the church did this then it
must be fine but excuse me these Ten
Commandments that holy mother the church
has given to the world are sparus they
are a lie they're not in harmony with
what scripture says and any fool that
puts the two next to each other will be
able to discern if he uses his own
judgment that they're not the same they
will have to because the church's
Commandments is the ones that is going
to be implemented Now isn't it
interesting Martin that certain Beaver
families in the world know which day is
the Sabbath day it's the Saturday that's
it but Humanity has to lay its judgment
aside watch the beavers and bees and
bees and maybe you can get an idea of
what the Sabbath day is all right Martin
let ask them who's the Boss
let's have a look so we we do have to
ask um since you are the superior
general of the of the Jesuits and Pope
Francis is our first Jesuit Pope who's
who's in charge between the two of you
do you do you report to him or does he
report to
you he is the
pope Pope so it's very clear but he's
still a Jesuit every
Jesuit reports to the to the Pope and is
maybe to to to explain that when a
Jesuit becomes a
bishop he the obedience is not more is
not anymore for the superiors of the
society no the bishop depends on the
pope and the popes
depends on himself on the
spirit so because as you maybe remember
ignasio the loola used to call the Pope
the beaker of Christ in Earth so he's
the pope so I'm accountable to
him unpack that a little bit for me
please I'm I I want to lay my
discernment
aside what did he just say well he said
the pope is relying on himself oh oh and
then he said Lia and gave all the things
to the pope because
relying on himself what does that make
him makes him
God amazing so pop Francis is he subject
to the black pope or is the black pope
subject to him being both
Jesuits uh Francis having sworn
allegiance to the one does he now swear
allegiance to himself or how does it
work obviously well let's continue this
discussion that he had on the
plane and Caroline beaza asks him good
evening Holy Father
uh I would like to know if you since
you've been Pope still feel yourself a
Jesuit his answer was it's a theological
question because Jesuits take the vow of
obedience to the pope but if the pope is
a Jesuits perhaps you should take a vow
of obedience to the general of the
Jesuits I don't know how this is
resolved I feel myself a Jesuit in my
spirituality in the spirituality of the
exercises
spirituality the one I have in my heart
but I feel so much like this that in 3
days I'll go to celebrate with Jesuits
the Feast of St
ignasius I will say the morning Mass I
haven't changed my spirituality no
Francis Franciscan no I feel myself a
Jesuit and I think like a Jesuit not
hypocritically but I think as a Jesuit
thank you Martin not hypocritically
I think he thinks hypocritically because
he totally ex negates the word of God so
this just sums up everything that we've
been coming up with that the and now we
know what the um exercises has to do so
if people want to say that he's a great
man he's the leopard has changed his
spot like we've had to do a whole
lecture on you can once again see out of
the horse's mouth no he has to rely upon
himself so M let's jump from one
so-called Holy Father of the Catholic
Church to the one who they call the
father of protestantism these days Rick
Warren I'm so glad I have one father and
that is the Father in Heaven amen and
Jesus Christ whom he has sent so let's
listen to this other father and see what
he has to
say SOI Warren in the purpose-driven
church said that the spiritual formation
movement had a vital message for the
church and has given the body of Christ
a wakeup call really Saddleback Pastor
Lance wit writes about the contemplative
prayer visualization this is ignatian
spirituality
100% in his article titled enjoying
God's presence in solitude we are
designed to enjoy the presence of God
but that's easier said than done Martin
he has promised to be with us in his
word in the article what uses Thomas
Merton what a Sublime example of debed
spirituality as an example of someone
who knew about Solitude Merton's
Solitude was connected to his Buddhist
sympathies meron likened contemplative
prayer to an Al
DP so I wonder if he could liken it to
it then he must have been on a couple of
them well that's the thing that out of
the hippie movement you had this uh
movie that came out a while back the
Jesus Revolution the preacher that came
out there he was still high on LSD and
all of those things when he started when
he was busy with the movement
M so I finished this article with the
goal of solitude is not so much to
unplug from my c world as it is to
change frequencies inducing Alpha
rhythms so that I can hear the father
what father are you hearing I think
you're hearing the father of Lies
unfortunately so let's have a look at
the alpha course and cell group
philosophy Martin this is runs deep
that's the thing you have to see first
we have to study what they actually
teach yes and now we're going to see how
it's implemented yes and how their
tentacles reach that's why they use the
octopus yeah as one of their symbols you
remember at one of the Olympic Games
they Ed The Octopus as a symbol they
know exactly what they're doing they
have their tentacles
everywhere all right so this is Nikki
Gumble the founder of the alpha course
so do they have Catholic Roots again
Martin these so-called
Protestants all right so let's have a
look at this Alpha course it consists of
10 weekly evening sessions exploring the
basics of Christian faith and has been
described as an opportunity to explore
the meaning of life the first Alpha
course evening is an introductory
evening to the course and includes
Refreshments with tea and coffee to cut
the brain supply of oxygen by
40% each weekly session looks at a
different question around faith and is
designed to promote authentic and open
discussion
we will be running an Altha youth
discussion group for students aged 11
to13 and then also for group 14 to
18 and it runs at New Life Church and
begins 28 January
2025 so are they busy with these things
it's still alive and well now the
founder he of course visited the pope
and received blessings and all these
kinds of things so what does it entail
we invite you
to you know explore life's big questions
social start we start an ala evening
with a time to just sit and chat to
other people on the course over a cup of
coffee or tea with some treats we have
found that the social time up front
helps us set a festive tone for the
alpha evenings right man so it's a it's
like a social Gathering it's to to bring
bring people into this Faith
relationship and what you what you want
when you have these courses you is you
want to have
consensus and you don't want to have
conflict so all conflict has to be laid
aside that means you can never introduce
an issue of Doctrine because that will
always create conflict and then also you
should be in harmony with your spiritual
guide the one is leading it the
so-called coach and once you have found
complete agreement with your coach then
you can
also well uh align your thinking and
your sympathies with the coach and he
can become like a father
Confessor so what you've introduced is a
Catholic system of
offloading what burdens you onto someone
who is now a representative the coach
yeah so again you have Seline Jesus
Christ and put another figure into the
center yes and you can't argue with what
he what your coach is saying so the
coach cracks the
Whip and he's well trained yeah okay so
let's continue then there's a
film series episode so after the social
then you have this topic will be
presented the sessions explore the big
topics around Faith these include who is
Jesus
how can we have faith why and how do I
pray and how does God guide
us well if he can guide you through the
spiritual exercises that would be
wonderful isn't it that's the problem
contemplation and all these kinds of
things and then you have a discussion
group now you read those topics that
being discussed it sounds wonderful
sounds wonderful but is there
anything that is controversial there no
not yet no also what's interesting
Martin is they they practice what is
called the 12 around one the coach and
the 12 that's a rosac crucian principle
which they claim is based on the
scripture of 12 disciples Around Jesus
right so each group will have about 12
people in each Discussion Group there's
no obligation to say anything and
there's nothing you can't say seriously
this is an opportunity to hear from
others with honest perspectives but the
one is going to take the leadership and
the guidance will be the coach it will
become into that okay let's reach
consensus so to date it is estimated
that over 30 million people worldwide
have done the alpha course and it's in
112 languages so it's doing a a job out
there right
mhm and this Alpha course is mostly in
Christian Protestant denominations
correct so in the alpha course the holy
spirit is mediated through the hands of
leaders and through the slain in the
spirit
experience that's already very very this
is getting very dangerous Alpha makes
the reception of the Holy Spirit and
outward manifestations The Mark of Faith
the published testimonies that come out
of alpha news nearly always concentrate
on the Holy Spirit experience as the
central aspect of
conversion rather than the Bible's
emphasis repentance from sin faith in
the crucified and Risen Lord with the
infilling of the Holy Spirit following
Acts 2:38 so this is a reversal of the
Bible model but it's presented in such a
way that you don't notice it yeah John
16:13 to4 how be it when he the spirit
of Truth is come he will guide you into
all truth now we have the definition the
word is truth that's it the Commandments
are truth Jesus is the truth let's not
talk about the Commandments let's not
talk about uh you know Jesus is the only
way let's not talk about the scripture
as the Norman the standard let's talk
about the spirit yeah for he shall not
speak of
himself but whatsoever he shall hear
that shall he speak and he will show you
things to come he will glorify
Jesus he shall receive of mine and shall
show it unto you so if Jesus doesn't
move into the center you have a problem
and it comes through studying the Bible
yes not through listening to what only a
coach has to say correct and they call
it the cell group now Martin a cell
originally was a monastic structure and
you know that even in
biology when the first cells were seen
under the microscope they were called
cells because they were like the monks
sitting in their separate little rooms
doing their little things so this is a
monastic terminology cell groups like
the Ala course cell groups also fall
under a coach or spiritual director they
are designed to bring people to
consensus theology celebration liturgy
and to the sacrificing of individual
Norms to group norms and Dynamics using
peer
pressure brilliant and without even
knowing without knowing it you don't
know it you don't know that there's peer
pressure it's just you don't want to
feel out so so let's just see how this
Jesuit spirituality comes
in here was a a book that was provided
in southern African context it comes
from layers scop school which is
Leadership School
and it's from the living word media and
the following quotes are from the
training manual for running effective
cell groups let's just see how this
works the cell group has a host a leader
a
Timothy and a
participants a cell group caters for
pastoral care individual needs and has
specific structure and duration it forms
the bridge between people and the church
every group member is evangelized
Consolidated and built up as a disciple
and sent then he's called
formed exactly that makes so because he
didn't he sent after they've taught him
and got him to do exactly what they want
then he's formed that's spiritual
formation the duration of a session is 1
hour and starts with an introduction
praise and prayer subject application
final activities deviation from the
format is not
permitted as members are not permitted
to change cell
groups murmuring and criticism is not
permitted Unity of thoughts feelings and
commitment are sought the disciples and
the cell group Vision cannot operate
independently of their leader Unity is
the symbol of
maturity this is out of the handbook out
of their Manual
Martin so you may not think for yourself
you must be aligned to the group and
especially to the spiritual leader the
coach I would run as far as I possibly
could from this coach because it sounds
so good and I know of a lot of people
you go to cell groups in your area the
church has a cell group so in the week
you've got your cell group gathering
this is to wake you up this is your
father Confessor
session and the you know what the
problem is it's it's wonderful to be in
those groups because these people help
each other they it's a it's a get
together it's a spiritually uplifting
experience experience okay models for
Success declare that success is yours
That's The Power of Positive
Thinking persevere dream and visualize
that power of positive thinking is what
Trump Donald Trump really promotes yes
wasn't it it it came from um Norman
Vincent PE and that is the 33 degree
Freemason he was if he was not a Jesuit
himself he was Jesuit
trained obedience and respect for
leadership is essential now I also say
we should have respect for leadership
for sure but if leadership leads you
astray instead of leading you to the
word of God then you must rebuke the
leadership and tell them to stop their
nonsense that's it you can't for the
greater good just just be
quiet the leader will seek counsel of
his or her trained Superior in the
church and the trust of his or her
disciples moreover the disciples must be
encouraged to confide in the leader
regarding their problems you have a
father Confessor no that's it exactly a
a a Catholic system just
infiltrated might not have no problem
with asking advice if you have a problem
but you know where you get your best
advice is on your knees and you see the
problem is like you just mentioned so
you've got these structures in church as
well but there is a correct way of doing
this this is Jesuit this is
Jesuit and then you have the 12 around
one model this is rosac crucian ISM this
is
occultism because it is a model based
supposedly on
Christianity used to pervert Christian
it Jesus took three and a half years to
train the 12 and so cell groups used the
12 around one concept Jesus did not
choose 13 but 12 with teams of 12 we
commence to restore the altar of God in
the world excuse
me Martin what is this the secret is in
the 12 the model of 12 has always been
in God's heart and the numbers
symbolizes government and
Authority so we now have a pope here on
Earth your spiritual advisor is like
your little Pope yeah yes so Mar we had
a school and we had seven students right
I think we will avoid 12 like the plague
that's it either 13 11 or 14 or
something but if it should be 12 if your
faith is weak you'll probably go back in
the knes I couldn't care less how many
there are or how few there are we don't
have in our explanation why we choose 12
no because there's no magical formula I
rely on the word not on this trly
nonsense we don't choose 12 people can
choose to come or not let's just make
sure that they are following this kind
of practice well here is a document from
the Rosen crucian fellowship and it
comes from their web page and they
clearly state state that the 12 signs of
the zodiac enveloping our solar system
the 12 semitones of the musical scale
comprising the octave the 12 apostles
are clustered around the C the Christ
not Jesus Christ please note Etc are
other examples of this grouping of 12
and one the rosac crucian order is there
composed of 12 brothers and the
13th there you go Martin a
cult it's amazing how they infiltrate it
and people don't even realize it let's
continue with with what they say in
their little manual a mentor is
described as someone with a Priestly
commission who is merciful and
sympathetic approved and
holy oh Bible says there's no one holy
no not one so if you want to call the
pope Holy Father it is a blasphemy
Beyond
blasphemies so Martin this is horrendous
and we have one priest and one priest
only and there's no priest on Earth we
are not sacrificial creatures we are not
sacrificing yeah we have one sacrifice
that has forever made perfect texts
quoted include passages from the Gospel
of John the book of Hebrews which refer
to Jesus and the ministry of the high
priest that ified the ministry of Jesus
very nice but now it's making it after
the antitype has already come it's
putting it back into the putting it back
into place that is
Catholicism midst many positive aspects
great emphasis is laid on fasting the
gifts of the Spirit Gifts of healing
prophecy power Miracles
tongues of course the function of the
holy spirit in convicting of sin
righteous n and
judgment uh that they ignore so this is
what we are writing here mtin the
student is also informed that Paul spent
most of his time praying in strange
foreign
tongues this is ridiculous Bible is very
clear on what the tongues means I thank
my God I speak with tongues more than
you all but he spoke ID dialecto in the
mother tongue of those that he was
addressing so this is such a perversion
of the scriptures it's
[Music]
unbelievable so spiritual exercises
versus Faith ISO Jesus versus EXO Jesus
ISO Jesus is what you read into the word
EXO Jesus is what the word really is
saying so ISO Jesus and EXO Jesus are
opposites of each other and EXO Jesus is
extracting from from the word what God
has put there so ignasius understood
more than any other leader of men this
is uh quoted from Burma professor of the
University of Bon about
Jesuits uh Les Jesuits Ignatius
understood more than any other leader of
men who preceded him that the best way
to raise a man to a certain ideal is to
become master of his imagination
we imbue into him spiritual forces which
we would find very difficult to
eliminate later it sounds like demon
possession to me yeah actually in
invoking the demon possession onto this
person correct Martin everybody who
practice the spiritual formation is in
one form or another demon possessed
unfortunately that's it and we saw now
how it can infiltrate through cell
groups yes forces more l ing than all
the best principles and doctrines get
rid of Doctrine all the time these
forces can come up again to the surface
sometimes after years of not even
mentioning them and become so imperative
that the Will finds itself unable to
oppose any obstacle and has to follow
their irresistible impulse so you become
a zombie no wonder they're making movies
about zombies Humanity has been
zombified through the spiritual excises
and zombies just just a Sidetrack but
zombies is also immortality of the Soul
yes it's it's totally um Jesuit teaching
correct Sam an ex New Age priest by the
name of Will Baron wrote The Following
the ritual was very
deceptive the average Christian would
probably find nothing seriously
objectionable about the phrases used
yet this meditation procedure was a
product of Satan designed to lead people
into accepting the voice of masquerading
demons as being the voice of the Holy
Spirit that's as clear as a bell that's
exactly what has happened all right
let's listen to what Martin Luther had
to say and then we'll take a quote from
the spirit of Prophecy Micah
75 trust ye not afraid
put ye not confidence in a guide keep
the doors of thy mouth from her that
lith in thy booom Martin that's a pretty
clear directive against spiritual
formation and spiritual directors and
coaches
yeah Martin Luther wrote the spirit is
nowhere more present and Alive than in
his own sacred writings we must let the
scripture have the chief place and be
its own truest simplest and clearest
interpreter I want scripture alone to
rule and not to be interpreted according
to my spirit or that of any other man
but to be understood in its own light
pery some and according to its own
spirit this is true Christianity and
meditation biblical medit on the word
that's biblical meditation reading your
Bible yeah not going off into a G state
but what is he saying help me to
understand what you are saying
Lord Spirit of Prophecy says let all be
educated to search the scriptures to be
constantly looking unto Jesus and not
the human agent to be their guide the
word of God is to be the man of our
counsel the word is infinite obeyed it
will guide us into safe and sure paths
but the word diluted with human devices
and imaginings is not a safe guide
Martin this is directly the opposite of
what's happening in the churches of
course and what we've just seen have
they drunken of the wine yeah here's
another quote God wants to do something
for each one of us the work is an
individual work mhm not some spiritual
director with his whopped ideas that
have been placed there by Jesuit
teachers it's a personal work students
do not depend on your teacher to form
your character form your character
spiritual formation for Christ's sake
make your character individually take
hold of God and do not think that you
ought to be always with your teachers in
order to be solid workers this is the
exact opposite philosophy yes here's
another one by these words Christ meant
that no man is to place his spiritual
interest under another as a child is
guided and directed by his Earthly
father this has encouraged the spirit to
desire ecclesiastical superiority you
may not differ from me I mean in the
handbook it even said there there's no
AR there's no differing or arguing with
the yes and if you have a problem you
may only come to me excuse me I get so
angry is it called righteous indignation
I hope
so which has always resulted in the
injury of men who have been trusted and
addressed as
father it confuses the senses of
sacredness of the prerogatives of God
there's another one as in earlier ages
the special truths for this time are
found not with the ecclesiastical
authorities but with men and women who
are not too learned or too wise to
believe the word of God Martin I don't
want to be so wise that I don't believe
the word of God I believe it from
Genesis to Revelation and if I should
differ from it then I will ask the Holy
Spirit to make me understand where I'm
wrong exactly so let's end with a few
Bible
verses Psalms 32:8 I will instruct thee
and teach thee in the way which Thou
shalt go I will guide thee with mine eye
it's a beautiful verse let God do the
guiding through his word yes I can
listen to lectures yes I can listen to
the opinions of of others but where they
differ from the word run yeah and when
you are not allowed to have an own
opinion exactly then get out get out of
there get out of there Isaiah 48:17 thus
says the Lord thy Redeemer the Holy One
of Israel I am the Lord thy God which
teaches thee to profit which leadth thee
by the way that thou should go let the
word of God be our guide and let us
listen to anything that is in harmony
with that word amen and uh I think there
we can end this first portion of the
discussion because unfortunately it's
going to get worse and not better that's
it there's so much more but we'll have
to show it in another one we'll do this
in the next round let's pray Heavenly
Father the deception runs deep ignatian
spirituality which is from the pits of
the bottomless
pit is what has infiltrated the whole of
the Christian Community commun and not
only the Christian Community but the
worldwide community and this will bring
about ecclesiastical
Unity based on
experience rather than the word of God
grant us wisdom grant us understanding
and above all things lead us into the
truth Thy word is truth this is my
prayer in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]